you only got to ask yourself two
questions and I hold on to these two
questions which whenever I'm trying to
make a major crew decision number one
you got to do the death bed test and
number two you got to do the plan B test
the death bed test is the simple
question you got to ask yourself which
is which of these choices would I regret
not doing more from the vantage point of
my deathbed the second thing is the plan
B test which is simply the question is
what are you gonna do if this doesn't
work out what's your plan B everyone's
degree of risk is different everyone
will have different levels of comfort
with like how much you're burning the
boats and how much you have something to
fall back on but those two tests the
deathbed test and the plan B test I
still use to illuminate big career
decisions